[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel awesome
Zorba report your source for everything
happening around the world in pop
culture and entertainment news i'm
heather ruse and I'm Ayane Wade and this
is your news for Monday July 23rd well
first of all earlier last week we got a
couple of announcements that we want to
talk about first of all on Twitter
stranger things released a promo for
season 3 which introduced us to a whole
new loop location of the star court mall
which was actually a really fun well
done promo so it shows that obviously
there's going to be the new location
there's lots of super old not super old
oh gosh the 80s aren't that old everyone
okay so most were born in the 80s I'm
sorry anyway the old 80's logos remember
the ma soeur doors and samples so like
old-school layers is in there yes yeah
they focus in on the old Gap logo
Waldenbooks Sam Goody which I spent way
too much money
uh-huh as a teenager because that was
the only mall store at least in my mall
that had any anime that you could buy so
I spent way too much money it was like
oh goody oh but then we are also shown
the food court where we see that Steve
is working at the classic scoops ahoy
ahoy ahoy it's an ice cream shop yeah if
you can't tell that from the scoops ahoy
right you know um I'm really hoping that
we're definitely gonna get to see this
mall in the upside down we have that
it's like built over some kind of portal
or something to the upside down it would
be there's so much potential oh yeah all
the different levels that people could
go to or be hiding in or from
maybe we get another kind of creature in
this one so we have the demagogue and
then we have the demo dogs and then now
maybe there's something else smaller we
seem to kind of be going in that
direction it's going to be hiding around
a mall demo rats
oh you can overlook a giant rat king
that would chase them around like food
cords if you don't know what rat king is
google it don't this might not actually
but they look evil they can be evil yeah
oh I'm very excited for the next season
yeah so if you're looking for that kind
of vintage mall feel just check that out
on Twitter yeah that's where they
release it they're really cool VHS
commercial II don't think yeah love it
earlier this week we also heard that
Rugrats it's getting a revival and they
keep pulling in a revival so we're not
quite sure if it's actually going to be
like a continuation of where they left
off or if it's going to be a whole new
version of the series but a lot of the
original creators are coming back as
executive producers so I'm really hoping
that bodes well that it's going to be
okay I mean honestly it's another thing
where I feel like is this really
necessary to come if I want if I want my
kids to experience Rugrats I'll just
like show them Rugrats I keep saying
that it's to introduce the new
generation of kids to you know Chucky
and Tommy and his pals but like again if
I wanted to do that I would just show
them Rugrats so right now it's just
gonna be 26 episodes we don't know if
any of the original voice actors or
anything are coming back but perhaps
even larger news with Rugrats is that
they are also getting a movie which is
like oh cool
but not just any movie it's a
live-action CGI mix which honestly
sounds a little terrifying because this
style of regret is not
meant for that kind of thing it's also I
could not I just can't imagine like CGI
large-headed
babies that talk it's it sounds terrible
absolutely terrifying and another
article was saying that it was CGI
capture like what what you gonna do
literally capture crawling babies and
then like popping up you know it's the
head honey of it like I don't oh no
sounds terrifying but like it already
has a release date like they're already
starting to produce it it's going it's
coming at us
November 13th of 2020 so I guess we have
some time to hear some news about it to
see if any of the original voice cast or
anything like that it's coming back but
that live-action movie sounds
nightmare-inducing
but this weekend was as many of you know
Diego Comic Con so San Diego Comic Con
this week and there were eight hon of
announcements trailers obviously things
that we cannot all cover with your minds
way too much yeah way too much happening
um so we're just gonna cover some of our
favorite things that we saw from this
weekend and one of the things that I am
super hyped about is Clone Wars Clone
Wars is saved it's coming back and then
they had a whole promo trailer for it so
I don't know if this means that it's
pretty well finished and they've been
working on this for a little while but
oh my gosh guys Clone Wars it's coming
back they're gonna finish it I have a
hunch maybe that is going to involve the
crimson dawn syndicate which if you saw
solo you know what I'm talking about if
you didn't I'm sorry but you'll have to
see solo and then see what I'm talking
about but I'm have a feeling it's gonna
maybe tie into that uh but I'm just
excited to see this series finished
yeah and I'm so pumped obviously they
got us some of the original points a lot
of the original
all of it I think original voice cast
back but if you watch the trailer at the
very end I like literally screamed when
the they have Anakin walk into a room
and he's like why did you bring me back
here and ahsoka turns around she's like
hi master it's been a while and I was
like which is how I even saw it in the
first place when I saw her tweet Clone
Wars save and I was like I'm sorry
yeah excuse me I gotta go I gotta go
check this out if you have not watched
Clone Wars it is all on Netflix right
now so you are denying yourself some
quality Star Wars content go watch that
and then get as hype designs exactly yes
we need you at this level there's tons
of other things but we also saw a couple
trailers firstly yeah we know that's why
you clicked on this it's that tightness
trailer we've always been bringing you
that Titans news here on orbit report
from the very beginning
yeah and as I think Dick Grayson said it
best oh okay yeah yeah yeah he said then
here's the thing so he's killing people
he's clearly going off the deep end
it's clearly you know DC taking a
different turn taking a darker universe
oh yeah the entry damn how super
interesting right that what's super well
with movies so yeah so in this trailer
we get to see it's mostly we're looking
at Raven and Dick Grayson kind of you
know going through their whole stories
we do get a little bit of stuff iron
there and a little bit of beach boy I'm
not 100% sold on the beast boy yeah yeah
I I have high expectations for him but
like you know I we haven't seen it all
yet so I'm waiting yeah but man this
seems like something in 2002 like circa
2002 Ayana would love you know what I
mean it's a very very angry
and super dark and super like we're not
the superheroes you think we are yeah
the young but were tough and it's I
don't know yeah I I was really let down
by the trailer I don't know because I've
been kind of excited to see some of the
costumes in Cabin I'm talking about and
then this was just like they took that
and then just jumped right over the deep
end my hope is that this is going to be
like Riverdale levels of cheese and
over-the-top or I'm just I'm here for it
okay because Riverdale is one of my
guilty pleasures everyone I love okay so
it's so over the top but in an amazing
way right so I'm hoping that this is
gonna reach like Riverdale levels of
cheese and darkness we're like they just
recognize and go for it but I'm I'm for
it I'm fine with it
I just feel like I need I need it to be
supported you know what I mean I it's a
trailer that's a little clicked 84 for a
very big reason it's good we're still
talking about it
right so I don't really have issues with
it you know it's that's what they gotta
do to get those views whatever yeah
another wheel row we also saw a glass
trailer and I actually didn't know that
split was in the universe I have missed
that movie but I did see unbreakable so
I'm really excited to have them come
together and obviously I'm gonna have to
see split before glass because there's a
therapist for disillusioned people who
believe that they are superheroes and so
we've got Bruce Willis coming back we've
got James McAvoy and we've got samuel
l.jackson and I'm very interested to see
where this goes and we don't have that
long to week because until January 2019
and so I'm not going to do the trailer
justice but you should go watch it yeah
that's very very interesting and there's
tons of other things that we missed so
you should hit us up on social media and
talk with us about them
Heather wears out for you you can find
me on Twitter Instagram or Twitter where
I stream on Tuesdays and Thursdays
awesome and then you can find me on
Facebook and everywhere else needed here
that's gonna be it from us here we're
gonna go watch some more sdcc stuff that
we missed
and we'll just catch you tomorrow on top
five in the meantime can you beam us up
[Applause]
you